Ласкаво просимо назад до курсу «Розуміння квантової інформації та обчислень». Мене звуть Джон Уотрас, і я є технічним
директором з освіти в IBM Quantum. Це одинадцятий урок серії і третій урок у
третьому розділі, присвяченому загальному формулюванню квантової інформації. Цей урок — про вимірювання, які являють собою
інтерфейс між квантовою та класичною інформацією. Коли над системою проводять вимірювання, поки вона перебуває у
квантовому стані, витягується класична інформація, що розкриває щось про цей квантовий стан і, як правило, змінює або
руйнує цей стан у процесі. У спрощеному формулюванні квантової інформації, яке розглядалося
в першому розділі серії, ми зазвичай обмежуємо свою увагу проєктивними вимірюваннями, включаючи
найпростіший тип вимірювання — вимірювання у стандартному базисі. Однак можливо узагальнити поняття вимірювання,
і це виявляється досить корисним. У цьому уроці ми поговоримо про вимірювання в повній загальності,
включаючи їх математичний опис і те, як вони вписуються в загальне формулювання квантової
інформації. Наприкінці уроку ми також розглянемо кілька фундаментальних понять, пов'язаних з вимірюваннями, а саме розрізнення квантових станів
та томографію квантових станів. Тож почнімо. Ось огляд
уроку. Як ми часто робимо, почнемо з основ, включаючи кілька різних, але еквівалентних способів
опису вимірювань у математичних термінах. Зокрема, вимірювання можна описати за допомогою наборів матриць,
а також можна описати їх як канали, на що я натякав у попередньому уроці. Ми також обговоримо часткові
вимірювання, тобто вимірювання, що проводяться лише над однією частиною більшої складеної
системи. Потім ми перейдемо до теореми Неймарка, яка є фундаментальним фактом стосовно вимірювань і яка в основному
стверджує, що загальні вимірювання завжди можна реалізувати простим способом, що нагадує представлення Штайн-Спрінга
для каналів. Коротко кажучи, загальні вимірювання завжди можна реалізувати, спочатку ввівши
ініціалізовану допоміжну систему, потім виконавши унітарну операцію і, нарешті, провівши вимірювання у стандартному базисі
над допоміжною системою. Це виявляється досить легко довести, і ми побачимо, як це робиться. Ми також
побачимо, як це пов'язано з так званими недеструктивними вимірюваннями, які я опишу. Нарешті, в останній частині
уроку ми обговоримо розрізнення квантових станів та томографію квантових станів. Почнемо з математичних
описів вимірювань. Вимірювання надають нам інтерфейс між квантовою та
класичною інформацією. Коли над системою проводять вимірювання, поки вона перебуває у деякому квантовому стані, витягується класична інформація
про цей квантовий стан. Крім того, квантовий стан, як правило, змінюється або, можливо,
повністю руйнується. Спочатку ми зосередимо увагу на так званих деструктивних вимірюваннях, де
квантовий стан надходить на вхід і виходить лише класична інформація, тобто не передбачається жодної специфікації
квантового стану системи після вимірювання. Інтуїтивно можна уявити, що деструктивне вимірювання
руйнує будь-яку вимірювану систему, тому її стан після вимірювання не
специфікується. Це не означає буквально, що фізичні пристрої обов'язково руйнуються — це лише математичний
опис, і він дуже корисний, бо допомагає спростити речі і зосередитися на суттєвих
математичних аспектах вимірювань. Існують зокрема два еквівалентних способи опису деструктивних
вимірювань, про які я згадував під час огляду уроку. Один спосіб опису деструктивного
вимірювання — за допомогою набору матриць, де для кожного можливого результату вимірювання є одна матриця.
Другий спосіб опису деструктивного вимірювання — за допомогою каналу, де
вхідним є стан вимірюваної системи, а вихідним — завжди діагональна матриця густини, яку можна
інтерпретувати як опис розподілу ймовірностей над можливими класичними результатами
вимірювання. Обидва описи еквівалентні, що досить корисно, оскільки дозволяє вибирати більш зручний опис у
конкретній ситуації. Ми також поговоримо про недеструктивні вимірювання, де крім класичного результату
вимірювання також специфікується квантовий стан вимірюваної системи після
вимірювання. Недеструктивні вимірювання важливі і часто зустрічаються, але в певному сенсі вони
не настільки фундаментальні, як деструктивні вимірювання в математичних термінах. Зокрема, виявляється,
що недеструктивні вимірювання завжди можна описати як композиції каналів і деструктивних вимірювань, і
ми побачимо, як це працює, трохи пізніше в уроці. Тепер поглянемо на те, як вимірювання, тобто деструктивні
вимірювання, можна описати як набори матриць. Протягом усього цього обговорення ми будемо припускати, що X — система,
над якою проводять вимірювання, і для простоти зробимо кілька припущень. По-перше, припустимо, що
класична множина станів X складається з цілих чисел від 0 до n мінус один для деякого додатного цілого числа n, і можливі
результати вимірювання — цілі числа від 0 до M мінус один, знову ж таки для деякого додатного цілого числа M. Не потрібно
встановлювати жодного зв'язку між числами n і M — обидва є довільними додатними цілими числами, і, звичайно, ми могли б замінити
ці множини довільними класичними множинами станів, якби захотіли. Для початку згадаємо, як працюють проєктивні
вимірювання, про які ми вперше говорили ще в третьому уроці серії. Враховуючи, що ми припускаємо, що
результати вимірювання — цілі числа від 0 до n мінус один, ми описуємо проєктивне вимірювання за допомогою набору
проєкцій Pi від 0 до Pi M мінус один, які в сумі дають одиничну матрицю, і всі ці матриці мають рядки та
стовпці, що відповідають класичним станам X, тобто всі вони є матрицями розміру n на n.
Якщо x перебуває у квантовому стані, описаному вектором квантового стану s, то кожен можливий результат
вимірювання a з'являється з ймовірністю, що дорівнює квадрату евклідової норми Pi a, помноженої
на вектор s. Квадрат евклідової норми будь-якого вектора дорівнює скалярному добутку цього
вектора на себе, тому ми отримуємо вираз, показаний на екрані, і можемо спростити його
трохи, використовуючи той факт, що Pi a є проєкцією, тому множення її на себе нічого не
змінює. І, нарешті, можемо переписати отриманий вираз дещо інакше, використовуючи циклічну властивість
WEBVTT
сліду, знову ж таки, як показано на екрані. І якщо незрозуміло, навіщо нам хочеться записати вираз саме так,
коротка відповідь полягає в тому, що ми хочемо зрозуміти, як проєктивні вимірювання працюють для матриць
густини. Зокрема, за лінійністю маємо: якщо стан X описується матрицею густини ро, а не
вектором квантового стану s, то ймовірність появи результату a дорівнює сліду від проєкції
Pi a, помноженої на матрицю густини ро. Так і має бути, оскільки, як ми бачили,
матрицю густини завжди можна розглядати як зважене середнє чистих станів, і якщо ми усереднимо
відповідні ймовірності, отримаємо цей вираз, бо слід є лінійною функцією. Отже, це той вираз, до якого ми прагнемо,
і можемо трохи спростити запис, зосередившись на матрицях
густини. Основна мета цього, до речі, — встановити точку відліку відносно вже вивченого
і побачити, що цей опис проєктивних вимірювань є, по суті, окремим випадком більш загального опису вимірювань, який ми
зараз розглянемо. Тому зараз я замінятиму цей опис роботи проєктивних вимірювань для матриць густини
на опис для загальних вимірювань, щоб ми могли зрозуміти зв'язок між ними. І ось він:
загальне вимірювання, не обов'язково проєктивне, описується набором позитивно напівдовизначених
матриць p від 0 до PM мінус один, які в сумі дають одиницю. Якщо це вимірювання проводиться над X, поки воно перебуває
у стані, описаному матрицею густини ро, то кожен результат a з'являється з ймовірністю, що дорівнює сліду PA *
ро. Коротко кажучи, єдина зміна полягає в тому, що ми послабили умову на ці матриці. Зокрема, матриці
не обов'язково мають бути матрицями проєкцій — вони просто мають бути позитивно напівдовизначеними. Відповідно я замінив літеру Pi на літеру p,
оскільки Pi — загальноприйнята назва для проєкції, тоді як я воліє використовувати літеру p для позитивно напівдовизначених
матриць. Це є узагальненням опису, який ми мали для проєктивних вимірювань, до речі, оскільки матриці проєкцій завжди позитивно
напівдовизначені, і насправді їх можна альтернативно визначити як позитивно напівдовизначені матриці, власні значення яких
можуть бути лише нулем або одиницею. Можна переконатися, що це визначення
є коректним у тому сенсі, що ми завжди отримуємо вектор ймовірностей для ймовірностей результатів ось так.
По-перше, ці числа, які я назвав ймовірностями результатів, завжди є невід'ємними дійсними числами —
тому що і PA, і ро є позитивно напівдовизначеними, і слід добутку двох позитивно напівдовизначених
матриць завжди є невід'ємним дійсним числом. Я залишу вам подумати, чому це так.
По-друге, числа мають у сумі давати одиницю, оскільки слід є лінійним, матриці
p від 0 до PN мінус один повинні в сумі давати одиницю, а матриці густини мають слід, що дорівнює
одиниці. Тому незалежно від того, яка матриця густини ро нам надана, ймовірності результатів завжди утворюватимуть
вектор ймовірностей. Тепер розглянемо кілька прикладів. Я вже зазначав, що
проєктивні вимірювання є окремим випадком загальних вимірювань, оскільки проєкції завжди позитивно напівдовизначені.
Але добре почати з простого, тому почнемо з вимірювання у стандартному базисі qubit. Вимірювання у стандартному базисі
qubit можна представити двома матрицями p 0 і P1, визначеними так, як показано на екрані. p 0 дорівнює кет-нуль бра-нуль, а P1 — кет-один
бра-один. Обидві вони є позитивно напівдовизначеними матрицями і, зокрема, проєкціями, і вони очевидно в сумі дають
одиницю. Отже, разом вони описують вимірювання. Якщо застосувати це вимірювання до qubit
у стані, описаному матрицею густини ро, то ймовірність результату нуль дорівнює сліду p 0 * ро,
а ймовірність результату один — сліду P1 * ро. За циклічною властивістю сліду ми отримуємо
два діагональних елементи ро, що й очікувалось. Ось ще один приклад, де
матриці вже не є проєкціями. Вони позитивно напівдовизначені і навіть є матрицями
густини, але це не важливо. Важливо те, що вони в сумі дають одиницю, тому разом описують
вимірювання. Ми можемо побачити, що відбувається, коли це вимірювання проводиться над qubit у стані плюс, — наприклад, просто для того,
щоб подивитися, як це працює на одному прикладі стану. Обчислення ймовірностей показано на
екрані. Зверніть особливу увагу на те, що хоча стан плюс є чистим станом і ми можемо представити його вектором квантового стану кет-плюс, нам доведеться
підставити представлення цього стану у вигляді матриці густини, тобто кет-плюс бра-плюс, у формули, щоб отримати
ймовірності. Зауважу також, що оскільки ми говоримо про деструктивне вимірювання, не існує жодної
специфікації квантового стану qubit після вимірювання. Тому все, що нам відомо, — це специфікація ймовірностей
результатів. Ось останній приклад на зараз, і він досить цікавий. Знову це вимірювання
одного qubit. Щоб описати його, почнемо з визначення чотирьох векторів квантових станів, відомих як тетраедральні
стани. Вони називаються тетраедральними станами тому, що відповідають чотирьом вершинам
правильного тетраедра, вписаного у сферу Блоха. Щоб було зрозуміло, під правильним тетраедром ми маємо на увазі
чотиригранне тіло, де кожна грань є рівностороннім трикутником. Тобто тут є ідеальна симетрія — кожне
ребро має однакову довжину, і між будь-якими двома суміжними
ребрами утворюється однаковий кут. Тепер можна визначити цікаве вимірювання з чотирма можливими результатами, як показано на екрані. Або словами: можна взяти
матриці як представлення цих станів у вигляді матриць густини, поділені на два. Це безумовно позитивно
напівдовизначені матриці, бо це матриці густини, поділені на два, і можна перевірити арифметично,
що вони справді в сумі дають одиницю. Але є інший спосіб це побачити — подумати про симетрію. Якщо усереднити ці чотири стани,
отримаємо повністю змішаний стан у центрі сфери Блоха. Але оскільки ми ділимо
кожен з них на два, а не на чотири, отримуємо подвоєний повністю змішаний стан, що є одиницею. Більше нічого не скажу про
це вимірювання зараз, лише зазначу, що воно не є проєктивним вимірюванням, але є гарним прикладом, і
ми ще зустрінемо його пізніше в уроці. Інший спосіб описати загальні вимірювання — за допомогою каналів, що ми зараз
розглянемо. Ідея полягає в тому, що класичні імовірнісні стани можна представити діагональними матрицями густини, тому,
оскільки результати вимірювань є класичними, можна думати про вимірювання як про канали, де вихід завжди є діагональною матрицею
WEBVTT
густини, що описує результат вимірювання. Тож розглянемо це детальніше. Якщо ми думаємо
абстрактно про загальне вимірювання, ми можемо описати його як канал фі. Вхідна система каналу — це
будь-яка система X, що вимірюється, а вихідна система — система Y, класичні стани якої відповідають
результатам вимірювання, які ми вважаємо цілими числами від 0 до n мінус один для деякого додатного цілого числа
M. Оскільки результати вимірювань є класичними, ми вимагаємо, щоб для будь-якої вхідної матриці густини ро для системи
X вихід «фі від ро» був діагональною матрицею густини. Наприклад, якщо думати про
вимірювання у стандартному базисі qubit і розглядати його як канал, ми можемо виразити його так, як тут показано на екрані.
Якщо вхідна матриця густини — ро, то результат нуль ми отримаємо з ймовірністю, що дорівнює бра-нуль ро кет-нуль,
а результат один — з ймовірністю бра-один ро кет-один. Якщо ми виразимо ці класичні
результати вимірювань у вигляді матриць густини, отримаємо цей вираз для відповідного каналу. І виявляється,
що це не що інше, як повністю дефазуючий канал. Це узгоджується з ідеєю про те, що повністю дефазуючий
канал є крайньою формою декогеренції, яка може означати різні речі, але коли я використовую цей термін, я
маю на увазі тенденцію квантових станів ставати класичними через те, що навколишнє середовище навколо будь-якої системи,
про яку ми говоримо, «спостерігає» в певному сенсі, або, іншими словами, вимірює її.
Отже, результати вимірювань можна описати як канали, як я щойно пояснив. Але це не просто можливість — це
характеристика загальних вимірювань. Ось що я маю на увазі: звичайно, існують канали,
які не відповідають вимірюванням, бо вихід може не завжди бути діагональною матрицею густини. Але якщо
вихід каналу завжди є діагональною матрицею густини незалежно від того, який вхідний стан ро ми вибираємо, то обов'язково можна
виразити цей канал у формі, показаній на екрані, для деякого вибору вимірювання — тобто набору
позитивно напівдовизначених матриць, що в сумі дають одиницю. Це корисно з кількох причин, включаючи те, що
це в основному говорить нам, що наше визначення вимірювань як наборів матриць нічого не
пропускає. Іншими словами, цей спосіб думати про вимірювання як про канали є операційним
або аксіоматичним у тому сенсі, що він фіксує те, чим має бути вимірювання — фізичним процесом, що
перетворює квантову інформацію на класичну. І виявляється, що це повністю еквівалентно нашому першому
опису вимірювань, який є суто алгебраїчним. Я не буду доводити еквівалентність у цьому відео, але
це не складно, і якщо зацікавився, можеш знайти доведення у письмових матеріалах до уроку, посилання є в описі відео.
Ми обговорили, що відбувається, коли загальне вимірювання проводиться над системою у заданому стані,
принаймні для випадку деструктивних вимірювань. Далі ми поговоримо про часткові вимірювання, тобто про те, коли
вимірюється лише одна частина складеної системи. Щоб бути точним, припустимо, що маємо пару систем XZ, які
разом перебувають у стані, описаному матрицею густини ро, і вимірювання, описане набором позитивно напівдовизначених матриць, що в сумі дають
одиницю, проводиться тільки над системою X. Природно, це призводить до
результату вимірювання, і оскільки ми говоримо про деструктивні вимірювання, можна уявити, що процес вимірювання руйнує систему
X. Але в нас залишається система Z, про яку потрібно думати, і треба зрозуміти, як вимірювання X впливає на
стан Z. Спочатку поговоримо про ймовірності
результатів. Оскільки ми говоримо про вимірювання лише системи X, ймовірності різних
результатів можуть залежати лише від стану X окремо, тобто вони можуть залежати лише від
редукованого стану X. Зокрема, ймовірність появи заданого результату a дорівнює
тій самій формулі, що й раніше — сліду PA, помноженого на редукований стан X, що ми позначаємо ро
підX. Стан ро підX отримується з ро вичерпуванням Z, тому ми можемо виконати цю
підстановку. І хоча це може бути не відразу очевидно, отриманий вираз можна альтернативно записати у вигляді,
показаному на екрані — це слід PA, тензорованого з одиничною матрицею на системі Z, помноженого на
ро. Це рівність, яку точно варто перевірити. Вона інтуїтивна — ми нічого не робимо з Z,
тому має сенс, що одиниця на Z з'являється таким чином. Але це можна також перевірити
алгебраїчно, і я залишаю це вам, пропонуючи спочатку розглянути випадок, коли ро є тензорним добутком двох матриць, а потім
скористатися лінійністю, щоб переконатися, що це справедливо для будь-якого ро. Також зауважу, що це не залежить від того, чи є PA
позитивно напівдовизначеною або ро — матрицею густини. Це рівність, яка б спрацювала для будь-якого вибору
матриць на місці PA і ро, якщо лише вони мають правильні розміри для того, щоб вираз мав
сенс. Тепер подивімося, як стан Z змінюється під час вимірювання. Природний підхід,
на мій погляд, — думати про вимірювання як про канал. Ось канал, який ми пов'язуємо з нашим вимірюванням. Ми
розглядаємо його як канал від системи X до нової системи Y, класичні стани якої відповідають результатам вимірювання. Тому в цій формулі
сигма відповідає стану лише системи X. Якщо ми застосуємо цей канал до
системи X, поки пара XZ перебуває у стані ро, отримаємо матрицю густини, що є тут. Знову ж таки,
приділи стільки часу, скільки потрібно, щоб перевірити це, і знову пропоную спочатку розглянути випадок, коли ро є тензорним
добутком двох матриць, а потім скористатися лінійністю. Ми бачили цей тип стану,
де перша система є класичною, а друга — квантовою, як приклад у
уроці про матриці густини. Кожне a з'являється з деякою ймовірністю, що є слідом другого тензорного множника, тому можна думати
про ці другі тензорні множники як про матриці густини, помножені на ймовірності. Отже, щоб отримати стан
Z за умови отримання конкретного результату вимірювання a, ми просто ділимо на ймовірність — тобто
нормуємо другий тензорний множник, ділячи його на власний слід. Отже, підсумовуючи, якщо ми виконуємо
вимірювання над X, поки пара XZ перебуває у стані ро, ось що відбувається. По-перше, кожен результат a з'являється
з ймовірністю, що дорівнює сліду PA, тензорованого з одиницею, помноженого на ро. По-друге, за умови отримання
WEBVTT
конкретного результату вимірювання a стан Z задається виразом, показаним на екрані, — це те, що ми отримуємо,
нормуючи матрицю, яку ми тільки-но бачили, і це те саме, що ділити матрицю на ймовірність
появи a. Зауважу, що це має сенс лише якщо ймовірність ненульова, бо інакше ми ділимо
на нуль. Але це нормально, бо нам не потрібно розглядати те, чого не відбувається. У цій частині
уроку ми обговоримо просту, але фундаментальну теорему про вимірювання — теорему Неймарка.
Коротко кажучи, вона стверджує, що будь-яке вимірювання можна реалізувати так, як
показує рисунок на екрані. Словами: задане загальне вимірювання над системою X можна реалізувати таким чином.
Спочатку ми вводимо ініціалізовану допоміжну систему Y, класичні стани якої є можливими результатами вимірювання — ми припускаємо, що вони
пронумеровані від 0 до n мінус один. Потім виконується унітарна операція U над парою
YX, і потім проводиться вимірювання у стандартному базисі над Y. Отже, тут усе в основному зафіксовано,
крім вибору U. Теорема стверджує, що насправді можна вибрати цю унітарну
операцію U так, щоб ймовірності різних результатів завжди збігалися із заданим загальним
вимірюванням. Тепер подивімося, як доводиться теорема Неймарка. Це нескладно — нам просто потрібно зробити вдалий вибір
унітарної операції U і перевірити, що вона працює. Але спочатку нам потрібен базовий факт
з теорії матриць: для будь-якої позитивно напівдовизначеної матриці P завжди існує єдина позитивно напівдовизначена
матриця Q така, що Q в квадраті дорівнює P. Взагалі-то може існувати багато матриць, квадрат яких дає P, але
серед них завжди є тільки одна позитивно напівдовизначена. Позначення для цієї матриці — квадратний корінь
з P, так само ми її і називаємо словами. Якщо ти хочеш обчислити квадратний корінь з P для деякої позитивно
напівдовизначеної матриці P, можна зробити це, спочатку обчисливши спектральний розклад P, а потім
замінивши кожне власне значення його квадратним коренем, залишивши власні вектори незмінними. Власні значення всі невід'ємні,
тому це має сенс, і досить легко переконатися, що отримана матриця справді є позитивно напівдовизначеною
і є квадратом P. Те, що вона єдина — інше питання. Це нескладно
довести, використовуючи деякі базові факти про матриці, але це дещо відволікає від уроку, тому ми просто приймемо цю частину
як дану. Тепер, маючи це поняття, досить легко специфікувати
унітарну операцію U, що підходить. Будь-яка унітарна матриця, що відповідає шаблону, показаному на екрані, справді
підійде. Перші n стовпців, припускаючи, що X має n класичних станів як раніше, отримуються шляхом стекування квадратних коренів
матриць, що описують вимірювання, одна на одній, а решта стовпців може бути будь-якою —
не має значення, аби вся матриця була унітарною.
До речі, якщо ти помітив схожість зі зв'язком між представленнями Крауса і Штайн-Спрінга для каналів — це не випадково.
По суті, те, що ми маємо тут, — це окремий випадок того, де наші матриці Крауса всі є позитивно
напівдовизначеними. Тому є дві речі, які треба перевірити. Перша — чи цей вибір U справді працює, і
друга — чи можна вибрати невизначені стовпці так, щоб U стала унітарною. Почнімо з першої.
Ось стан, з якого ми починаємо: нижня система Y ініціалізована у нульовий стан, тоді як верхня система
починає у стані ро. Потім ми виконуємо U, тобто спряжуємо з
U. Ми можемо записати все це у термінах блокових матриць, як показано на екрані. Ліворуч маємо U, праворуч U дагер,
а в середині — кет-нуль бра-нуль тензорований з ро у формі, яку ми маємо тут, де ро знаходиться у
верхньому лівому куті, а всюди інде — нулі. Якщо подумати про цей добуток, стає очевидно, що
невизначені елементи U взагалі не мають значення, бо вони завжди множаться на нульові елементи цієї
середньої матриці. Якщо виконати множення, отримаємо ось цю
матрицю, показану тут, описану як блокова матриця, або ж можна виразити її у нотації прямої суми
ось так. Це, власне, зручніша форма для нас, тому зосередимося на цьому
виразі. Для зручності назвемо цю матрицю, яка є матрицею густини,
сигмою. Останній крок — вимірювання у стандартному базисі над Y. Тому обчислимо редукований стан у Y,
і це просто, враховуючи наш вираз. Ми просто вичерпуємо X, що відповідає другому тензорному
множнику. Тому ймовірність появи будь-якого заданого результату a — це діагональний елемент, що відповідає a. Можемо записати
це ось так, і це дорівнює сліду квадратного кореня з PA, помноженого на ро, помноженого на квадратний
корінь з PA. За циклічною властивістю сліду отримуємо слід PA * ро,
на що ми і сподівалися. Тому ймовірності появи різних результатів правильні — вони завжди збігаються
з вихідним вимірюванням, з якого ми починали. Друга річ, яку треба перевірити,
— чи можна заповнити невизначені стовпці U так, щоб вона стала
унітарною. Це випливає з того, що перші n стовпців, які утворені квадратними коренями матриць, що описують
вимірювання, є ортонормальними. Це можна перевірити досить безпосередньо. Відповідні деталі тут,
на екрані. Тому поставмо відео на паузу і приділімо кілька хвилин, якщо хочеш. Але, як я зазначав раніше,
це, по суті, окремий випадок того, з чим ми стикалися в попередньому уроці. І це
завершує доведення. Поки що в уроці ми зосереджувалися на деструктивних вимірюваннях, тобто де не специфікується
квантовий стан вимірюваної системи після вимірювання. Для недеструктивного вимірювання, з іншого боку,
є не лише класичний результат вимірювання, але й квантовий стан вимірюваної системи після вимірювання, і, як
ми побачимо, існує природний зв'язок з теоремою Неймарка. Насправді існують різні способи формулювання недеструктивних
вимірювань у математичних термінах, але почнемо з одного формулювання, яке фактично випливає безпосередньо з теореми Неймарка.
Розглянемо загальне вимірювання — деструктивне — описане набором позитивно напівдовизначених
матриць p від 0 до PN мінус один, що в сумі дають одиницю. Потім ми можемо перетворити це
WEBVTT
вимірювання на недеструктивне, просто розглянувши реалізацію цього вимірювання, яку ми обговорювали в контексті теореми Неймарка.
Ми вводимо нову систему Y, взаємодіємо її з X через унітарну операцію U і потім виконуємо вимірювання у стандартному
базисі над Y. Тому система X залишається, і ми можемо розглянути її
стан. На основі аналізу, що ми провели, можна визначити, що стан X після вимірювання за умови
отримання конкретного результату a задається матрицею густини, яка виглядає
ось так. Словами: ми спрягаємо з квадратним коренем відповідної вимірювальної матриці, а потім
нормуємо. Інший спосіб формулювання недеструктивних вимірювань, більш загальний, — у термінах матриць Крауса
каналів. Це визначення вимірювань, яке ти знайдеш, наприклад, у відомому підручнику Ніла і
Чуана. Припустимо, що m0 через m m мінус один — квадратні матриці, що задовольняють
рівняння, показане на екрані, тобто ми могли б думати про ці матриці як про матриці Крауса, що описують
канал. Насправді ці матриці описують канал, але вони також описують недеструктивне вимірювання.
Коли над системою у заданому стані ро проводять вимірювання, спочатку ймовірності результатів
задаються рівнянням, показаним на екрані. Кожен результат з'являється з ймовірністю, що дорівнює сліду ma *
ро * ma дагер. А за умови появи результату a стан вимірюваної
системи виглядає ось так. Недеструктивні вимірювання такого роду можна реалізувати
аналогічно до того, що ми мали для теореми Неймарка. Залишаю це тобі подумати, якщо
хочеш. Можливо узагальнити поняття недеструктивного вимірювання ще далі. Наприклад,
існує поняття так званого квантового інструмента, що іноді буває досить корисним, але я не розглядатиму це в цьому
відео. В останній частині уроку я коротко обговорю два завдання, пов'язані з вимірюваннями: розрізнення квантових станів і томографію квантових
станів. Є дуже багато чого сказати про обидва ці поняття, і ми лише торкнемося їх
поверхні. Тож почнімо з уточнення того, що ці терміни означають і чим вони відрізняються.
Перше — розрізнення квантових станів. Ідея полягає в тому, що ми маємо відомий набір квантових
станів деякої системи разом з ймовірностями, пов'язаними з цими станами. Щоб бути точним, припустимо,
що ро від 0 до ро M мінус один — матриці густини, що представляють можливі квантові стани системи X, а p від 0
до PN мінус один — ймовірності, пов'язані з цими станами. Тому якщо ми зберемо ймовірності в один
вектор, отримаємо вектор ймовірностей. Лаконічний спосіб сказати це, до речі, — що ми маємо ансамбль квантових
станів. Тепер абстрактний спосіб думати про розрізнення квантових станів як про задачу або як про проблему
такий: спочатку число між нулем і N мінус один вибирається випадково згідно з ймовірностями. Потім система X
підготовляється у стані, що відповідає випадково вибраному числу, і мета — визначити за допомогою
вимірювання X, яке число було вибрано. Отже, ми маємо скінченну кількість
альтернатив разом з апріорним розподілом, і мета — визначити, яка альтернатива насправді мала місце. Для деяких виборів станів та
ймовірностей це може бути просто, а для інших — неможливо зробити без деякої ймовірності помилки.
Є різні конкретні питання, які можна ставити, наприклад: яка мінімальна ймовірність помилки
і як виглядає вимірювання, що досягає цієї мінімальної ймовірності помилки? Томографія квантових станів, з
іншого боку, відрізняється. Тут ми маємо невідомий квантовий стан системи, тому зазвичай
немає апріорного розподілу чи будь-якої інформації про можливі альтернативи. Але цього разу доступна не одна копія стану,
а багато незалежних копій. Тобто для деякого, можливо великого, числа
n ми маємо n ідентичних систем X1 через Xn, кожна з яких незалежно підготовлена у стані
ро. І мета цього разу — знайти апроксимацію цього невідомого квантового стану у вигляді матриці густини шляхом вимірювання
систем. Отже, підсумовуючи: у розрізненні квантових станів ми маємо одну копію
стану і намагаємося розрізнити серед скінченної кількості відомих альтернатив. У томографії квантових станів ми маємо багато незалежних
копій невідомого квантового стану, і мета — знайти опис цього стану або принаймні пристойну апроксимацію
нього. Розрізнення квантових станів цікаве тим, що воно абстрагує тип ситуації, що часто виникає в
обчисленнях і криптографії, наприклад, де одна альтернатива зі скінченного набору можливостей відбулася і ми або хтось інший намагається
визначити, яка саме, вимірюючи квантову систему. Найпростіший нетривіальний випадок —
коли є лише дві альтернативи, тобто m рівне двом. Завдання — розрізнити пару
станів. Цей випадок виявляється фактично повністю вирішеним, припускаючи, що мета — мінімізувати
ймовірність неправильного розрізнення. Існує оптимальний вибір вимірювання, і його часто називають
вимірюванням Гельстрома. Це насправді проєктивне вимірювання, і воно може бути описане
так. Спочатку ми розглядаємо зважену різницю між двома альтернативами, тобто p 0 * ро 0 мінус P1 * ро один.
Тобто ми множимо ймовірність отримання кожного з цих двох станів на самі стани і беремо
різницю. Це ерміт'єва матриця, бо вона дорівнює своєму спряженому транспозованому. Тому вона має спектральний
розклад, і ми знаємо зокрема, що всі власні значення є дійсними числами. Припустимо, що ми маємо
спектральний розклад у формі, показаній на екрані. Далі ми збираємо
власні значення у дві множини: всі позитивні власні значення — в одну, і всі негативні власні значення — в
іншу. Точніше, нехай S0 — множина всіх індексів k, для яких відповідне власне значення лямбда K є
невід'ємним, і нехай S1 — решта індексів, тобто ті, що відповідають від'ємним власним
значенням. Насправді не має значення, яка множина містить індекси, що відповідають нульовим власним значенням. Ми робимо
довільний вибір — включити в мінус нуль, але не було б жодної різниці, якби деякі або всі вони були включені в S1. Головне —
відокремити позитивні та негативні власні значення. І, нарешті, визначаємо дві проєкції Pi
0 і Pi 1, як показано на екрані. Словами: Pi 0 — проєкція на
WEBVTT
підпростір, натягнутий власними векторами, що відповідають невід'ємним власним значенням, а Pi 1 — проєкція на підпростір,
натягнутий власними векторами, що відповідають від'ємним власним значенням. Це справді проєкції, і
якщо додати їх, отримаємо одиничну матрицю, бо власні вектори S від 0 до S N мінус один утворюють
ортонормальний базис. Якщо це вимірювання виконується в ситуації, що розглядається, тобто
стан, що вимірюється, — ро 0 з ймовірністю p 0 і ро один з ймовірністю P1, то виявляється, що
ймовірність правильного визначення має досить просту формулу в термінах власних значень лямбда від 0 до лямбда N мінус
один. Я не буду розбирати деталі обчислення у цьому відео. Можеш переглянути письмовий матеріал за посиланням в описі відео, якщо
зацікавився, або спробуй самостійно переконатися, що ця формула справді правильна. Ми можемо також виразити цю
ймовірність за допомогою матричної норми, яку зазвичай називають слідовою нормою. Позначення схоже на евклідову норму для векторів,
але з нижнім індексом один, що вказує на слідову норму. Слідова норма дуже важлива і дуже часто
зустрічається у квантових обчисленнях, але я не буду багато розповідати про неї в цьому уроці. Один спосіб
визначити її для ерміт'євих матриць — це сума абсолютних значень власних значень. Тому можна думати
про цю другу рівність як про таку, що безпосередньо випливає з цього визначення. Слідову норму можна також
визначити іншими, більш загальними способами, і ми знову зустрінемо слідову норму в наступному уроці. Це справді
найкраще, що можна зробити. Це вимірювання є оптимальним, якщо мета — максимізувати ймовірність правильної
відповіді. Цей факт іноді називають теоремою Гельстрома-Голева, а іноді просто теоремою
Гельстрома. Тому це вимірювання неможливо перевершити за ймовірністю правильності, і це гарно, бо
є простий рецепт для самого вимірювання і точна формула для ймовірності правильності в термінах слідової
норми. Слідова норма часто використовується як спосіб вимірювання спостережуваної різниці між матрицями густини саме
з цієї причини. Коли люди говорять про слідову відстань між станами, вони зазвичай мають на увазі
половину слідової норми різниці між двома матрицями густини, що тут відповідає випадку, де p 0 і P1 обидва рівні 1/2, а це
природний випадок для розгляду. Розрізнення квантових станів для двох станів оптимально вирішується
вимірюванням Гельстрома, для якого ми маємо простий рецепт і просту формулу для ймовірності
правильності. Що ж відбувається, коли ми хочемо розрізнити три або більше станів? У цьому випадку ми не маємо
загальної формули для оптимального вибору вимірювання або простого виразу для максимальної ймовірності
правильності. Однак можливо знайти добру апроксимацію оптимального вимірювання за допомогою комп'ютера.
Зокрема це можна зробити за допомогою справді захоплюючої і потужної техніки оптимізації, відомої як напіввизначене програмування, але це не
те, що можна реалістично реалізувати за допомогою олівця і аркуша паперу. З іншого боку, якщо хтось
дає тобі опис вимірювання і стверджує, що це вимірювання є оптимальним для задачі розрізнення квантових станів, то
насправді дуже легко або підтвердити, або спростувати це твердження. Це можна зробити за допомогою так званих умов Голева-Яна
Кеннеді-Лакса. Я не буду пояснювати, що це таке, в цьому відео, але вони є простими умовами і досить круто,
що це можливо. Ось приклад, який пов'язується з тетраедральними станами,
які ми бачили раніше в уроці. Припустимо, нам дається один з цих чотирьох станів, вибраний випадково з
ймовірністю одна четверта для кожного, і наша мета — визначити, який саме стан нам дано. Можливо, це не дивно, але
найкращий вибір вимірювання для цього — тетраедральне вимірювання. Не завжди можна зробити
щось подібне для довільного набору чистих станів, але завдяки симетріям тут це
спрацьовує, і ми справді отримуємо коректне вимірювання. Через умови Голева-Яна Кеннеді-Лакса, які я згадував
кілька хвилин тому, виявляється, що досить просто довести, що це справді оптимальний вибір
вимірювання. Зокрема, тут відбувається те, що вимірювання правильне з ймовірністю 1/2, що не так
погано, бо є чотири альтернативи, тому ймовірність правильної відповіді вдвічі краща, ніж випадкове вгадування, і це
виявляється найкращим, що можна зробити для цих станів. Тепер скажу ще трохи про томографію квантових станів,
де ми маємо багато незалежних копій невідомого квантового стану і мета — знайти апроксимацію матриці густини, що описує
цей стан. Насправді існує кілька різних варіантів цієї проблеми, залежно від твоїх припущень, і зокрема
від того, які вимірювання ти допускаєш. Наприклад, ми могли б вимагати, щоб кожна система вимірювалася окремо, і
результати якось поєднувалися для отримання опису матриці густини. Або ми могли б дозволити, щоб усі
системи вимірювалися разом як одна складена система, що набагато краще теоретично, але і набагато більш
вимогливо технологічно. Крім вибору вимірювань, є ще одне важливе питання —
як реконструювати опис матриці густини з тих даних, які ти отримав від вимірювань. Я не буду
заглиблюватися в деталі. Моя мета — просто підкреслити, що томографія квантових станів — це скоріше загальна концепція, що має
багато різних варіантів, а не єдина процедура. Було проведено велику кількість досліджень цієї проблеми, включаючи кілька
нещодавніх проривних результатів, що пов'язують кількість копій n з точністю апроксимації, яку можна досягти, і це
залишається цікавою та активною сферою досліджень. Щоб завершити урок, поглянемо на томографію квантових станів
для qubits та як її можна виконати. Тож припустимо, що ро — матриця густини, що представляє стан
одного qubit, а X1 через Xn — qubits, всі незалежно підготовлені у стані ро. Для
цього обговорення припустимо, що n велике. Що ми можемо зробити — це розділити
системи на три приблизно рівні частини. Для першої частини виконаємо вимірювання відносно базису плюс-мінус. Для кожного результату, що відповідає плюс, ми нараховуємо плюс один, і для кожного
результату, що відповідає мінус, — мінус один. Більш лаконічний спосіб описати це вимірювання
— сказати, що це вимірювання Паулі X, бо стани плюс і мінус є власними векторами матриці Паулі X, і
результат, що відповідає мінусу, ми поставимо мінус один. Більш лаконічний спосіб описати це вимірювання —
це вимірювання Полі X, тому що стани плюс і мінус є власними векторами матриці Полі X, а
відповідні власні значення — плюс один і мінус один, і насправді це набагато поширеніший спосіб описати його, і
дійсно очікуване значення рахунку дорівнює сліду сигма X * ро. Ми не обов'язково дізнаємося, яке це очікуване значення, але якщо ми усереднимо рахунки, отримані
протягом дуже великої кількості спроб, дуже ймовірно, що отримаємо пристойну
апроксимацію цього очікуваного значення за законом великих чисел. Є кілька добре відомих статистичних меж, які ми можемо застосувати
до цього, якщо хочемо бути більш кількісними в цьому твердженні. Ми робимо аналогічне з сигмою Y на другій третині
систем. Єдина зміна полягає в тому, що ми використовуємо стани плюс I і мінус I, які є власними векторами сигми
Y, і аналогічно для сигми Z, для якої стандартні базисні вектори є власними
векторами. І, нарешті, ми можемо скористатися формулою, показаною на екрані, яка говорить нам, якими мають бути коефіцієнти,
якщо ро записується як лінійна комбінація матриць Паулі. Підставляючи наші апроксимації для цих коефіцієнтів
і можливо трохи коригуючи їх, щоб переконатися, що отримаємо позитивно напівдовизначену матрицю, ми отримаємо апроксимацію
ро. Звичайно, є деталі, які я не розглянув, наприклад точність апроксимації і ступінь
впевненості, на яку ми можемо розраховувати, але сподіваюся, що це дає тобі базове уявлення про один зі способів виконання томографії
qubit. Також можливо виконати томографію qubit за допомогою тетраедрального вимірювання, і насправді це виявляється
досить простим і елегантним, принаймні в математичних термінах. Що ми можемо зробити — виконати лише
це одне вимірювання над усіма незалежними копіями нашого невідомого квантового стану. Використовуючи
дивовижну формулу, показану тут, ми можемо скласти апроксимацію нашого стану, оцінюючи слід PK *
ро для кожного K за часткою, з якою з'являється відповідний результат вимірювання. Знову ж таки, це працює лише завдяки
ідеальним симетріям серед цих чотирьох станів. Насправді існують дуже цікаві нерозв'язані задачі, що пов'язані з узагальненнями
цього підходу до більших систем. На цьому гарне місце, щоб завершити урок. Дякую за перегляд, і
сподіваюся, що ти приєднаєшся до мене в наступному уроці, присвяченому очищенням та вірності. До побачення!